sans quasi aucune menace.
Dans le Pantanal, en plus des colliers GPS, nous utilisons une autre technique :
des caméras-pièges.
Ces caméras sont équipées d'un détecteur de mouvement
et elles photographient les animaux lorsqu'ils passent devant.
Grâce à ces appareils fantastiques,
nous avons pu récolter des informations précieuses
sur la reproduction des tapirs et leur organisation sociale
qui sont des pièces importantes du puzzle
lorsqu'on essaie de développer des stratégies de conservation.
Et là maintenant, en 2015, nous étendons encore nos travaux
au Cerrado brésilien,
les prairies ouvertes et les forêts de buissons dans le Brésil central.
Aujourd'hui, cette région est l'épicentre du développement économique de mon pays,
où l'habitat naturel et les populations sauvages
disparaissent rapidement à cause de différentes menaces,
incluant une fois encore l'élevage de bétail,
les grandes plantations de cannes à sucre et de soja,
le braconnage, les collisions routières, pour n'en citer que certaines.
Et on ne sait comment, les tapirs sont toujours là,
ce qui me donne de l'espoir.
Mais je dois dire que lancer ce nouveau programme au Cerrado
était un peu comme une gifle.
Lorsqu'on se promenait
et que l'on voyait des tapirs morts le long des autoroutes
et des traces de tapirs errant dans les plantations de cannes à sucre
où ils ne devraient pas être,
et qu'on parlait aux enfants qui disent connaître le goût de la viande de tapir
car leur famille les braconne et les mange,
ça vous brise vraiment le cœur.
La situation du Cerrado m'a fait réaliser...
Cela m'a donné la mesure de l'urgence.
Je nage à contre-courant.
J'ai réalisé que malgré deux décennies de dur labeur
à essayer de sauver ces animaux, il y a encore tant à faire
si nous voulons empêcher leur disparition.
Nous devons trouver les moyens de résoudre ces problèmes.
Nous le devons, et vous savez quoi ?
Nous en sommes arrivés à un point dans le domaine de la conservation
où il faut sortir des sentiers battus.
Nous devrons être bien plus créatifs que ce que nous avons été jusque là.
Et comme déjà dit, les voitures sont un grand problème pour les tapirs au Cerrado,
nous avons donc eu l'idée de mettre un autocollant réfléchissant
sur les colliers GPS placés sur les tapirs.
Ces autocollants sont aussi mis sur les camions
pour éviter les accidents.
Les tapirs traversent les routes dans le noir,
les autocollants pourront aider les chauffeurs à voir les lumières
traversant la route,
et peut-être ralentiront-ils un peu.
Pour l'instant, c'est juste une idée folle.
Rien n'est sûr. Nous verrons si le nombre de collisions avec des tapirs diminuera.
Mais l'important est que c'est peut-être ça, le genre d'initiatives à prendre.
Bien que toutes ces questions se pressent
dans ma tête pour le moment,
j'ai un contrat avec les tapirs.
Je le sais au fond de moi,
la conservation des tapirs est ma cause.
C'est ma passion.
Je ne suis pas seule.
J'ai ce grand réseau de sympathisants derrière moi,
et il est impensable que je m'arrête un jour.
Je continuerai très probablement pour le reste de ma vie.
Et je le ferai pour Patricia, mon homonyme,
un des premiers tapirs que nous ayons capturés et surveillés en forêt atlantique
il y a des années.
Et pour Rita et son bébé Vincent au Pantanal.
Je continuerai pour Ted, un bébé tapir capturé
en décembre, l'année dernière aussi au Pentanal.
Nous continuerons
pour les centaines de tapirs que j'ai eu le plaisir de rencontrer
au fil des ans
et pour tous les autres que je rencontrerai dans le futur.
Ces animaux méritent notre protection.
Ils ont besoin de moi. De nous.
Et vous savez ? Nous, les humains, méritons de vivre dans un monde
où nous pouvons voir et jouir,
pas seulement des tapirs,
mais de toutes les autres merveilleuses espèces,
maintenant et dans le futur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)